superman might be the world's most
famous superhero but
clark kent is pretty impressive in his
own right still there's a whole lot even
the most
die-hard fans get wrong about superman's
mild-mannered alter-ego
here are a few of the biggest
misconceptions about clark
kent when it comes to pulling off
incredible feats of heroism people tend
to go with the invincible
alien superman over the demure reporter
clark
kent i'm here to fight for truth and
justice in the american way
as such you might think that kent isn't
all that when he's not wearing the red
and blue spandex
but the truth is while kent's second
life as a superhero tends to overshadow
his journalistic accomplishments that
doesn't make them any less impressive
his byline frequently appears on the
front page of the daily planet
arguably the most widely read newspaper
in the dc universe's version of the
united states
and while there aren't many comics about
kent conducting lengthy interviews and
typing at his computer direct evidence
of his award-winning track
record appears in the legendary mark
wade and alex ross comic kingdom come
the scene in question starts with kent
who's going by his kryptonian birth name
khalel chatting with wonder woman
outside the watchtower
kalel is halfway through recalling a
recent final encounter with brainiac
when he mentions that some of the
villain circuitry has been hidden inside
a pulitzer in clark kent's apartment
take note he says a pulitzer not
the pulitzer suggesting that incredibly
kent might actually have more than one
one of superman's constants throughout
the character's 80 plus years of history
is the tension between his small town
upbringing and his adult life in the
fast-paced metropolis of
metropolis as such whenever someone
accuses the concept of superman of being
old-fashioned
that someone is usually talking about
clark kent's midwestern identity
rather than anything specific to
superman as a hero
indeed the wholesome norman
rockwell-esque image of the american
bread basket that
underlies smallville does scan as a
little quaint
but the clark kent character isn't as
old-fashioned as you might assume
take one of the other constants in
superman's life the romance between him
and lois lane if kent's really such a
slack-jawed hayseed
then how could a sophisticated cynical
journalist like lois be in love with him
it's also worth considering that
traveling to unfamiliar countries tends
to be enough to broaden a person's
horizons
and can't spin to a whole bunch of
different planets
which would suggest that his horizons
are plenty broad no matter how simple
his upbringing may have been
so while it may be totally fair to call
clark kent square in the huey lewis
sense of the word don't go thinking he's
a man of the past because the truth is
he's anything but
clark kent's need to keep his superhero
identity hidden from the world is one of
the most important aspects of the
character
and he's gone to some pretty crazy
lengths to do it too
so it might be easy to imagine that the
world will never really know superman's
secret
but this all changed in february 2020
with the release of superman volume
5 number 18. in this story superman gets
burned out on keeping secrets and
finally lets the world know the truth
that he's actually been the daily planet
reporter and smallville native clark
kent this whole friggin
time of course the status quo is never
static for long in the world of dc
comics so it's impossible to know how
long superman's identity will remain
public knowledge
but until the next continuity reset or
massive retcon
changes everything back again the heroes
and citizens of the dc universe will
continue to know
that clark kent is really superman for
better or for worse
plenty of people wrongly assume that
batman and superman
are natural adversaries and the blame
for this misconception doesn't fall
entirely on zack snyder's shoulders
either
while batman vs superman certainly
popularized the notion that the two
characters hate each other
the pop culture commentator chuck
klosterman described their relationship
as that of arch
enemies in a 2007 essay almost a full
decade before the release of snyder's
film
on top of that the comics themselves
have occasionally pitted the two against
each other in a wide variety of contexts
and while it's true that clark kent and
bruce wayne have a very complicated
relationship you only need to take a
cursory glance at some more recent
superman stories
to know that the friendship between
these two heroes plays a crucial role in
the dc universe
a recent run of batman even commemorated
their bond with a two-part arc in which
each hero agonizes over the other being
far more noble brave and kind-hearted
than themselves
they then promptly get over it go on a
double date with lois and selena
and visit a batting cage where they
argue over whether bruce can land a hit
on clark's kryptonian fastball see
they're practically best buddies
so here's a question just how close are
clark kent and bruce wayne
well turns out they're such pals that
they've even traded outfits on a handful
of occasions
that's right clark kent is batman well
sometimes
in tom king and clay mann's run on
batman bruce wayne dresses up as
superman and clark kent dons the cape
and cal this is pretty much their
only option in the moment as they're
trying to meet the costume criteria for
superhero night at the gotham county
fair without revealing their secret
identities
a glass is wearing kent batman is
exactly as funny as it sounds too
especially when lois lane has to talk
him out of using his super strength to
win her a carnival prize
in another instance mind controlling
nanites take bruce wayne
out of action in a 1998 episode of
superman the animated series leading
clark kent to temporarily take up the
mantle of batman
right here look familiar bane
ah yes bane kent and tim drake
eventually rescue their brooding
colleague and in the process
prove something long suspected of
superman that with the possible
exception of the joker he can brush
aside the bulk of batman's rogues
gallery without much effort
can't see batman dispatching doomsday so
easily can you
time to up the ante bruce ask someone
the most important difference between
clark kent and superman and they'll
probably tell you it's the fact that
clark kent wears glasses
it's also pretty well known that this
flimsy little disguise is enough to fool
everybody kalel meets but some people
have seen through the disguise such as
one particularly sly resident of gotham
city
during bruce wayne and selena kyle's
engagement kent expresses some
reservations about meeting his buddy's
new fiance
after all revealing his secret identity
to a former super criminal seems like a
pretty risky bet
but lois lets her husband know that
selena seems naturally gifted at
figuring out people's secrets and that
the chances are she already knows who
kent really is
the very next page finds batman and
catwoman watching over the gotham city
skyline
the feline fatale quickly confirms
lane's suspicions
riley pointing out that a little hair
gel and a pair of glasses isn't quite
the foolproof disguise that clark kent
thinks it is
though catwoman is far too insightful to
fall for clark kent's silly glasses
routine
it's worth pointing out that pretty much
everyone else does in grant morrison and
frank quietly's all-star superman for
example
even those nearest and dearest to kent
can't seem to put two and two together
lex luthor allegedly the smartest man in
the whole world
looks a glasses-less ken right in the
face and makes no connection whatsoever
in another scene the staff of the daily
planet watches as kent stares down a
powered-up luther
when it becomes obvious that this is
actually superman confronting his
nemesis
jimmy olsen simply suggests that
superman has disguised himself as clark
kent
of course you could argue that it's hard
to recognize a godlike superhero when
he's standing next to you at the water
cooler and some people do look totally
different when they're wearing or not
wearing a pair of glasses
still though you'd think that some of
the world's greatest reporters might
have caught on by now
frank miller's the dark knight returns
might be a pretty great comic but it was
the worst thing to ever
happen to clark kent's reputation this
iconic comic book story sees a
ronald reagan-esque united states
president order superman to bring in
batman whose tactics don't fall in step
with the government's new anti-vigilante
regulations
batman quite rightly accuses his justice
league co-founder of
spinelessness in the face of well
basically anyone with a badge or a flag
thus one of the most famous superhero
stories of all time
successfully makes the point that the
most famous superhero of all time
is kind of a chump but while the dark
knight returns portrayed kent
as differential and servile he hasn't
always been the kind of guy who has to
do whatever authority figures tell him
in fact superman has brought down
president lex luthor on a few different
occasions and in one instance he even
goes
full man of steel and outright fries
luther's democratically elected brains
and then there's justice league
unlimited the macro plot of this 2004
animated series revolves around superman
refusing to play ball with high-ranking
government employee amanda waller
so don't go thinking kent doesn't know
how to play the rebel when it suits him
still you've got to hand it to mid-1980s
frank miller
only he could convince the world that
superman would attack batman
because the president thought batman was
fighting crime too hard
clark kent is the original superman and
the default superman and no one's ever
gonna make the case to the contrary
but he's not the only superman in fact
during dc's
line-wide future state event clark kent
isn't superman at all
instead that designation belongs to
jonathan kent clark's son with lois lane
overall though clark has had an easier
time hanging on to the exclusive use of
his famous
alias than some of the other heroes out
there but let's not forget the brief
period following clark's death in the
90s in which steele
hank henshaw conor kent and the
eradicator were all briefly and
unofficially considered superman
in one of the most memorable chapters of
superman the animated series bizarro
also successfully passes himself off as
the genuine article
for about a day oh how could he
i'm superman me
me still nobody apart from clark seems
able to hold down the gig
for very long so does this mean that
being superman is more difficult than
say being spider-man
well who could say but a whole lot of
people have been spider-man over the
years
and only one man seems able to pull off
being superman
something to consider don't you think to
most people the names superman and lois
lane
seem like natural bedfellows the abc
series lois and clark only strengthened
that connection in the 90s and 2021 cw
series superman and lois is likely to do
the same but clark kent and lois lane
haven't been romantically involved for
the entirety of their respective
fictional existences
as many readers may be aware clark's
high school sweetheart and ongoing
semi-platonic gal pal is actually lana
lang
sporadically throughout the last roughly
40 years worth of comics
superman has also gotten romantically
tangled up with princess diana of
themyscira
in fact superman and wonder woman have
far more in common than lois and clark
or diana and steve trevor for that
matter but every time these two heroes
get together sooner or later they
usually end up back with their
traditional partners
maybe that's just because those
characters need to periodically reset to
their status quos
or maybe it's because wonder woman and
superman always get to know each other
as superheroes and neither can live up
to those hyper idyllic first impressions
but lois well she first meets him as
clark kent a regular old joe from kansas
so her expectations for their
relationship are just a little more
grounded
probably makes for a simpler date night
too check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
you